all right everybody i've been getting a
ton of requests to cover the latest
spider-man no way home league that does
seemingly confirm that andrew garfield
is indeed going to be in the film and
the great thing about this leak is it's
actually coming from a big official
website unless this was the biggest
marketing mistake a website and company
could have made of all time which i
doubt it was this is indeed the real
thing now some of you may have seen this
before possibly yesterday but i'm going
to take it a step further today because
i think that i have figured out a key
part of spider-man no way home and i
think i may have figured out the
marketing technique that sony is going
to use eventually when they start fully
pushing and promoting spiderman no way
home so after we talk about the leak
i'll talk about their marketing plan
what to expect from their marketing plan
and when can we expect to receive things
like that second trailer because
remember sony is actually in charge of
the marketing for this one yes they do
have to consult with marvel for it but
according to disney's president of
marketing sony is in control so we can't
expect the norm as far as trailers are
concerned so be sure to subscribe and
hit that notification bell so you don't
miss out on any of the latest spider-man
videos and i definitely do a lot of them
so let's start with this leak this is
from an official skittles website the
official skittles russian website on
this website it actually shows andrew
garfield spider-man for their official
promo for spider-man no way home this
was originally discovered by twitter
user at spider-man 3 news and this is
the official skittles website for their
promotional partnership with sony
pictures as spider-man no way home this
is an official partnership and since
it's an official partnership that means
that skittles can't do anything without
consulting with sony first any website
design any promotion that they put on
the website none of that can go up until
sony says that's fine and lo and behold
what do we have here right smack dab in
the middle of the website right when you
enter it andrew garfield spider-man and
if you're questioning this you can
actually go to the website yourself it
is still there as i'm speaking right now
i have refreshed the page it's still
there you can go to
skittlespromo.ru slash
trailer and when you go to the website
the first thing you see is andrew
garfield spider-man pop up with a play
button over him and when you hit that
play button it sends you straight to the
trailer for spider-man no way home in
russian on sony's official russian page
so this is all 100 official coming from
sony and the huge corporation skittles
now here's the deal this image is taken
from the promotional still from the 2014
the amazing spider-man 2 it is simply
flipped around and some people are
arguing that this could have simply been
a mistake now if this was a mistake it
had to be the worst mistake ever
especially when you consider it's about
spider-man no way home if you give us
something about one of the other two
spider-man being in the film we will
take it but this is not a mistake here's
the deal like i mentioned in the
beginning of this video this is a
promotional partnership skittles just
doesn't have free will and the ability
to do anything they want with this promo
and then simply launch it that is not
how this works it is a partnership in
which sony 100
has to sign off on everything that
skittle does for their promo i do
sponsored videos on my youtube channel
you've seen other youtubers do sponsored
videos as well and when we do these
sponsored videos we don't just get told
what to do and then post it we have to
send it back to the company and they
have to approve it before we can put it
online and it's entirely the same case
for this promo right here and since this
promo is already live this is what
happened sony told skittles what they
should do for their promo skittles did
it they did it with andrew garfield
spider-man smack dab in the main page
they sent it back to sony for them to
sign off of and approve and sony
approved it that is why it is now live
on the website there's just no way that
skittles does this on their own sony had
to approve it before which makes
something very curious about the website
of course andrew garfield being on it
but if you look on the site we can see
some text in russian and when translated
it reads there is no way home and i
actually think that this is going to be
a big plot point for the movie and a big
plot point for their marketing campaign
i think in the next trailer we're going
to get a full sinister six reveal i
think they're going to reveal all of the
villains of the movie and i think
they're going to reveal that they are
from different universes from older
universes the sam raimi and amazing
spider-man universes and i think they're
going to reveal that now that they're in
the mcu our universe they can't get back
home now considering what we know about
how the villains get brought into our
universe they are taken right from that
point before they die in their
respective universes so i doubt the
villains even want to go back home
because if they do go back to their
universe they'll probably get put back
in the same exact spot and a recent plot
leak that has been proven to be somewhat
true says that this is indeed their fear
they don't want to go back because
they'll believe that they'll just die
but i don't think this is just for the
villains i think it's for the other two
spider-man as well i think it's for
andrew garfield spider-man and toby
mcguire's i don't think they could get
back to their own respective universe so
easily if you think about it spider-man
no way home that title doesn't really
apply to tom holland i guess you could
say it could in the fact that his life
is now pretty much destroyed and maybe
his universe is going to change but i
really think this is going to be for
everybody else and i kind of think that
this is going to be a marketing point
for sony and marvel kind of like
avengers avenge the fallen was i can see
perfectly posters of each of the
villains with the words on them there is
no way home and i can also see this for
the other spiderman once they reveal
them and i actually don't think that
we're going to get that much marketing
for this film at this point sony knows
that this is the worst kept secret in
hollywood everything literally points to
toby maguire spider-man and andrew
garfield spider-man being in this movie
everything major trade companies and
websites have reported that the other
two spider-man are coming back insiders
have reported it we have skittles
official website putting andrew garfield
on the front page we have villains from
the other two spider-man's universes now
in the main mcu confirmed by the trailer
everything points to them being in the
film this is a horribly kept secret so
what does sony plan to do about this
well they probably plan on not really
giving us much their mindset is probably
well you already know so we're going to
make you wait till the film so you don't
know too much think about it we don't
even have an official poster for the
movie yet we're basically just two
months away from the movie and we don't
have an official poster and we don't
have an official trailer a full-length
trailer if the rumors are true we should
be seeing toby mcguire and andrew
garfield pop up in the official trailer
not as themselves but in their
spider-man uniforms and apparently it'll
give us just enough of a tease to let us
know that they are indeed in the film
now when can we expect this well we've
heard november is most likely and that's
going to be only a month before the film
actually comes out but it looks like
they're going to wait until after the
eternals comes out if you've noticed the
marketing for the eternals has ramped up
by a lot like a lot it's pretty much
going to be like shangchi we got the
teaser trailer the main trailer another
trailer and then we're going to get a
lot of different tv spots and other
promotions as well and this is going to
be a really big movie for marvel studios
a movie that could win a lot of awards
so they're going to keep the focus on
the eternals while it's in theaters and
right before it comes out as well so it
does make sense that they would hold off
on promoting spider-man no way home
until after the eternals has had a few
weeks in the box office or kind of put
it right with the eternals that way they
can play the trailer before the eternals
either way i don't think we're actually
going to get a lot of promotion for no
way home and if we do i think it's going
to be a lot of the same footage but i
can really see the theme of no way home
being there is no way home for each
person for each villain and for each
spider-man and heck maybe even doctor
strange as well we know that that spell
didn't go according to plan and who
knows what's going to happen to him but
we do know that all of this is going to
lead up to multiverse of madness so
maybe it's a big problem for him as well
but let me know what you think about
this in the comments down below let me
know what you think about this andrew
garfield skittles lake out of all places
skittles don't forget to like the video
and for live updates you can follow me
on instagram and twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching woof
you